this is GMC 2019 model I'm going to
program it at8 ke using the aut km
100 so let's see how it's working
this so connected device this is new
remote it's not working see
h
for
y
okay I'm go to
GMC
okay
so GMS here 2019
model
yes manual
selected T MC
see
179 smart
key H
function add a smart
key
start do you want to R code
yes
for
three pin Cod is Success press
enter do you want to start process no
need do you want to learning
yes say smk learning please press start
button and stop once Press
buttons place the key to be lared to the
slot this is a new one and the old one I
keep the far away so new one I puted the
slot is here in the
middle I put it and press
okay
okay switch technition is off
already so it's take 12 minutes time you
have to wait 12 minutes after 12 minutes
we going to show you how
to the next procedure what to
do so I'm going to push a video
here
so we have finished 12 minutes now I
start it
again press start button
once ready for remote three now ready
for remote 4 cuz success already program
it
the remote is completed you want next so
if you want to next more remote you can
press yes if you don't need more press
no switch ignition off
off ignition
okay press stop button for 12
seconds just keep on pressing for 12
seconds okay release start
button
press the long start Buton press the
long press the start button to switch
ignition on okay so presses the long
press to switch ignition is
[Music]
on switch ignition
off
default brake to start
car okay start the
[Music]
card switch ignition
off okay no this stop the ignition close
and open the
door okay so you're going to open door
and close you take the
remote and press
the lock and unlock button at the same
time so we going to press lock and
unlock button together and release it
then press
okay there is any other no just it
finish so now before watch two keys now
it's already three keys it's completed
press
okay
it's success we can try the new new
remote new remote is
working as you can see you can rest
start the
car
everything and we can try the old one
also still is
working this old one and this new one is
working